tina pour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat vous le savez journée
spéciale aujourd'hui consacrés aux
travaux de la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur l'efficacité de la lutte
contre le dopage mercredi dernier les
sénateurs ont auditionné david
lappartient le président de la
fédération française de cyclisme
audition que je vous propose de suivre
tout de suite mes chers collègues m
merci de voir rejoint cette commission
denquête nous commençons nos travaux
aujourd'hui par l'audition de monsieur
david lappartient président de la
fédération française de cyclisme
je signale plus moi je rappelle comme
avant chacune des auditions que les
personnes qui nous rejoindrait dans le
public sont tenus de conserver le
silence et d'allemagne et de manifester
ni approbation ni d approbation sur les
propos qu'elle entendront
l'infâme aussi personnes auditionnées
que un faux témoignage devant notre
commission seraient passibles de
sanctions pénales
et puis je dois terminer le côté
procédural en demandant messieurs
lappartient de prêter serment dire la
vérité rien que la vérité devait la main
droite et dire je le jure je jure merci
en général et on fera pas d'exception
aujourd'hui c'est rencontre commence par
la possibilité donnée la personne
auditionnée de s'exprimer pendant
environ un quart d'heure plus ou moins
deux minutes n'est pas à cheval sur la
durée pour nous faire part de ce qu'il a
à nous dire sur ce problème de la lutte
contre le dopage
vous allez donc qu on le fait à chaque
fois pouvoir monsieur appartient vous
exprimer je me permettrai si vous
dépassez par trop la durée prévue de
vous l'indiquer simplement mais bon en
général avec un quart d'heure vingt
minutes au maximum on arrive à situer le
sujet qui nous occupe donc je vais vous
laisser la parole est ensuite le
rapporteur les autres membres
la commission denquête auront sans doute
des questions à vous poser des comme
promis je vous donne la parole tout de
suite pour la période que vous jugerez
utile merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs c'est avec beaucoup de plaisir
tout d'abord je me trouve aujourd'hui
devant vous pour vous donner le point de
vue où l'analyse de la fédération
française de cyclisme que je représente
ce la lutte contre le dopage et plus de
répondre aux questions que vous
manquerez pas de me de me poser alors si
je commençais par une note optimiste ce
serait aussi bien en vous disant que ça
va mieux dans notre sport et qu'on le
voit au quotidien et tous les jours
alors la lutte contre le dopage c'est
souvent le verre à moitié plein au verre
à moitié vide fort c'est quand même de
constater que si tout n'est pas parfait
les choses se sont améliorées continue
de s'améliorer
parce que pour nous fédération française
de cyclisme mais comme pour la plupart
des acteurs du sport en général
le dopage c'est tout simplement la
négation des valeurs du sport et donc
nous combattons toute forme de tricherie
à la fédération française de cyclisme
quelle qu'elle soit mais avant de venir
peut-être sur chaque a pu faire notre
fédération quelles sont les pistes pour
améliorer parce que c'est un des
objectifs certainement
quelles sont les pistes pour améliorer
la lutte contre le dopage convient
peut-être de faire un rapide retour
peut-être sur une un aspect plus
historique que vous connaissez
certainement j'ai vu que vous avez
auditionné aussi bon nombre dont nombre
d'acteurs mais plus particulièrement
avec le prisme du sport qui est le mien
même si je sais que vous avez rencontré
beaucoup de personnes du monde du
cyclisme
il faut pas se cacher notre sport a été
parmi les plus touchées en matière de
dopage
et ceci depuis quand même détendez temps
relativement anciens et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que notre sport a toujours
été parmi les premiers à mettre en place
un certain nombre de mesures sont
remontés jusqu'aux premiers contrôles
antidopage un petit peu avant les années
70 il ya eu ensuite de véritables
avancées que ce soit par la mise en
place de contrôles sanguins par les
interdictions de le paix au par la mise
en place du passeport biologique du
suivi médical réglementaire bref tout un
tas d'actions qui concourent quand même
globalement amélioré l'état sanitaire du
peloton mais on a vécu quand même des
affaires qui ont été des séismes dans
notre sport jeux qu'on serait bien sûr
par l' affaire festina en 1998 que tout
le monde connaît de sinistres de
sinistre mémoire
et puis plus récemment la faire la ferme
strong même si personnellement je
n'avais pas beaucoup de doutes sur la
crédibilité ces résultats cette affaire
n'a fait que confirmer les soupçons que
l'on pouvait avoir
et donc dès lors rapporté bas
à une nouvelle image désastreuse de
notre sport
parce qu'on al'impression finalement que
les affaires se succèdent les unes aux
autres
sauf que les affaires qui se succèdent
sont aujourd'hui des affaires je
l'espère pourra s'attendre l'entraînent
relativement ancienne et bien on espère
que les choses vont aller vont aller
s'améliorant pas mais dans les affaires
de dopage vous trouvez toujours deux
ingrédients nécessaires dans notre sport
il ya tout il y a toujours un directeur
sportif à la vertu douteuses et un
médecin qui est dans le même état
d'esprit et si vous n'avez pas et l'un
et l'autre ça ne
ça ne fonctionne pas on va dire en
matière de dopage donc et bien sûr un
coureur qui si ce n'est qu'ils réclament
qui au moins acceptent de ne pas poser
trop de questions ou subir et donc mais
vous avez systématiquement
systématiquement les deux parce que vous
ne pouvez pas avoir des directeurs
sportifs qui ignorent ce qui se passe
chez eux et en tout cas qu'il ferait ça
sent la complicité de certains médecins
donc et ça quand même durablement altéré
l'image du cyclisme
c'est vrai que quand on regarde parfois
le grand public on peut se dire cyclisme
égale dopage alors que il n'en n'est au
jour d'aujourd'hui et c'est plus du tout
le cas
dpz il ya encore blessure de dopage dans
notre sport il serait faux aujourd'hui
bien sûr de le nier mais les efforts
sont quand même payant parce que bien
avant les autres nous avons su nous
saisir de ce problème de l'ue dopage et
d'apporter des solutions à la lutte
contre le dopage
si je comparais je dirais que nous
sommes nous dans un tunnel mais on était
à la sortie du tunnel et on voit le jour
d'autres rentrent juste dans le tunnel
et je pense que c'est le tunnel du mont
blanc pour certains d'entre eux ils vont
y être pour pour un certain temps et
donc pour ce qui nous concerne nous on
se réjouit à chaque fois que des
nouvelles mesures de lutte contre le
dopage peuvent être mises en place il ya
eu c'est vrai des vraies avancées au
niveau international avec la création de
l'agencé mondiale antidopage en france
le cpl des puits la fld mais si je
m'autorise cette comparaison un peu
simpliste dans le cyclisme il y a comme
au bord de la route pour ceux qui ont un
petit peu trop vite en voiture chez nous
il ya un radar
et à la patrouille à la à l'arrivée pour
arrêter les contrevenants
il ya certes un sport qui met juste le
radar ya pas de patrouille et à d'autres
sports qui manie le radar ni la
patrouille donc forcément tout va bien
d'un point de vue statistique que pour
eux alors que l'état de leur sport est
sensiblement plus dégradé que le nôtre
sachez encore que en matière de
localisation
quel est vraiment le sport qui joue jeu
pour la localisation des athlètes c'est
quand même là aussi le cyclisme c'est
nécessaire et pour la crédibilité de
notre sport c'était nécessaire et moi je
souscris tout à fait à l'obligation de
localisation de l'ensemble des athlètes
même si cela est dur et même si parfois
ça peut conduire effectivement à la
pression pour certains athlètes d'être
sans arrêt gendarmes et écouter observer
la crédibilité de notre sport passe par
là et certains sports collectifs
mériterait à mon avis d'avoir le même
traitement que nous plutôt que de
choisir tel ou tel d'athlètes
accessoirement pas forcément de
meilleurs qui va faire le la
localisation et donc on a vécu quand
même dans notre sport des périodes
difficiles
je ne me suis pas caché tout à l'heure
et très objectivement la crédibilité des
résultats du cyclisme entre 1996 et une
période de situer aux alentours de aux
alentours de 2005
après on n'a pas forcément la date
exacte mais ça continue de s'améliorer
la crédibilité quand même sérieusement
altéré pendant cette période là et moi
je n'accorde pas de crédibilité
particulière aux résultats sportifs de
cette période on l'a vu avec avec la
ferme strong si on prend mines entre
1996 et 2010 un seul des quinze
vainqueurs du tour de france n'a pas été
impliqué dans une affaire de dopage et
c'était pas celui à la plus mauvaise
réputation en plus
donc quand on connaît son surnom dans
limite dans les en espagne mais ça veut
dire que voilà on a eu une période très
très difficile au 2 mai au demeurant
mais depuis deux trois ans je trouve
très sincèrement qu'on revoie du vrai
vélo
d'abord ça roule moins vite ça ne vous a
pas échappé si vous observez calme le
vélo quand je discute avec des coureurs
du peloton le dise président
très objectivement ça roule moins vite
on prend le départ d'une course avec
l'ambition de gagner
lors que disons par avance avec on avait
ramassé une dérouillée donc les coureurs
français et d'autres coureurs sont
revenus à l'ambition on revoit du vrai
vélo on voit des vrais défaillance on
voit des athlètes qui vont moins vite
qui sera soit plus tôt donc ça veut dire
que nous sommes très clairement sur la
bonne voie mais il n'y a pas de victoire
définitive n'est définitive contre le
dopage
il faut continuer de lutter de lutter
sans cesse et lutter tous les jours mais
nous souffrons dans notre sport d'avoir
aussi certains managers qui furent à
l'époque et celles et ceux qui ont amené
le vélo sans doute dans cette tricherie
dans laquelle il a été pendant une
période et qui aujourd'hui sont quand
même propriétaire d'un certain nombre d'
équipe et c'est cela qu'on ne voudrait
plus voir dans le cyclisme et donc
j'aurai peut-être des propositions très
concrètes à vous faire parce que ceux-là
font souffrir notre notre sport mais
notre sport à la volonté de s'en sortir
à la volonté de lutter contre le dopage
on n'est pas nous par exemple comme à la
coupe du monde de football il me semble
bien qu'à la coupe du monde de football
la dernière il n'y a pas eu de contrôles
sanguins parce que ça coûtait trop cher
c'est vrai que la fifa n'a sans doute
pas les moyens de pouvoir mener des
contrôles sanguins à mon avis que ça
servait à rien et que ça coûtait trop
cher
donc voyez un petit peu la différence
effective mandat proche entre l'ensemble
des des sports alors si j'en viens plus
particulièrement au travail de la
fédération française de cyclisme
c'est un peu normal je suis là aussi
pour dire que ce travail a été a été
exemplaire mais je le pense très
sincèrement puisque sans relâche et mes
prédécesseurs avant moi que soit le
président balle le présent à la philippe
le président pitallier ont eu de cesse
de lutter contre le dopage est de mettre
en place des nouvelles des nouvelles
mesures
j'ai été élu je suis à 100 cinquième
mandat à la fédération
et donc j'ai été élu relativement tôt
mais je me suis en 1996 quand daniel
balle alors à l'époque présent de la
fédération roger logel présent de la
ligue nationale du cyclisme et jean
marie leblanc donc à l'époque directeur
du tour de france avait lancé un appel
solennel au président du cio à l'époque
à la ministre je crois que c'est marie
george buffet aussi à l'époque
pour dire aider nous parce que notre
sport part dans des errements qu'il nous
faut à tout prix corriger et donc
c'était l'appel de 1996 et nous y avons
répondu ensuite à la fédération en 1998
en mettant en place ce qui d'ailleurs
sous tend la loi française maintenant
aussi qui était le suivi médical
longitudinale contrôler ce qui est
devenu maintenant le suivi médical
réglementaire de par la loi mais qui
était à l'époque son appel le mlc et qui
a été votée et j étais cette séance du
comité directeur de la fédération
une semaine avant la sphère festina donc
on a souvent dit que la fédération avait
pris dès les mesures en conséquence de
l'affairé festina c'était une semaine
avant la sphère festina et donc la
sphère festina nous est arrivé ensuite
en pleine figure mais à conforter le
choix des élus de la fédération et le
cyclisme français a fait cette occasion
là une véritable révolution culturelle
et nous continuons nous avons amélioré
le modèle du suivi médical
réglementaires etc suivi médical
réglementaire a d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
et est traduit dans la loi puisque les
fédérations sportives et pas que la
fédération civile les fédérations
sportives ont obligation et c'est une
obligation du présent de la fédération
de mettre en place un suivi médical
réglementaire pour les athlètes de haut
niveau et pour les athlètes en lice
d'espoir que nous nous étendons aussi
aux amateurs de haut niveau donc on doit
suivre un petit peu moins de 1200
athlètes donc c'est énorme ça coûte
quand même de l'argent à la fédération
bien aidés quand même par le par les
ministères faut le reconnaître mais donc
nous avons ce suivi médical
réglementaire qui aujourd'hui a été
déclinée à l'ensemble des fédérations
mais il est bien sûr la base de ce que
la fédération française de cyclisme a
imaginé en 1998 et moi j'ai souvenir
d'ailleurs à cette époque d'un présent
de la fédération daniel balles dont on
connaît la transigeant ce en matière de
lutte contre le dopage crois qu'elle est
reconnu par tout ce qu avait même été
mis en examen pour complicité à l'époque
dans ces affaires de dopage avant
d'avoir à des non lieux les plus rapides
de l'histoire puisque au bout de quinze
jours il avait eu un non lieu
mais c'est vous dire à l'époque l'image
de la fédération mêmes mots prennent un
certain nombre de juges alors qu'elle a
depuis largement évolué puisque nous
sommes systématiquement et c'est une
position constante de la fédération pas
dix civils dans tout les affaires de
dopage je vous cache pas qu'au tout
début on avait du mal à ce que notre
constitution de partie civile soit jugée
recevable en dix ans au mieux
vous n'avez pas vu au pire vous êtes
complice et maintenant c'est plutôt l
inverse tout le monde effectivement
reconnaît les efforts que nous avons
fait et nous n'avons plus de difficultés
à faire reconnaître notre constitution
de partie civile
j'étais encore la semaine dernière en
guadeloupe parce qu'on a aussi des
problèmes très claire dans ce dans ce
dans ce département d'outre-mer
jétais pour un procès sur de trafic de
produits dopants dans le cyclisme
notamment avec neuf prévenus qui ont été
pour lesquels des peines de prison avec
sursis ont été demandés et j'ai été
aussi porté les convictions de la
fédération devant le tribunal de pointe
à pitre donc nous le faisons
systématiquement dans toutes les
affaires de dopage et on croit que c'est
nécessaire de le faire
nous faisons aussi bien sûr toute la
prévention nécessaires auprès des jeunes
et ça c'est particulièrement une de nos
missions nous avons beaucoup de jeunes
nous expliquons fectivement quels sont
les dangers et comment éviter les
écueils du les écoles du dopage mais
paradoxalement je pourrais dire on a
presque moins de problèmes avec le
cyclisme professionnel qu'avec quelques
clubs du cyclisme du top cycle top
niveau amateur français pourquoi parce
que l'encadrement est moins serré et
donc on a un cyclisme professionnel
français malheureusement on a vu un cas
qui est arrivé la semaine dernière donc
tout n'est pas parfait mais en tout cas
qui va qui va beaucoup mieux
ainsi que des amateurs aussi ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir quelques soucis
encore y compris donc au haut niveau
amateur mais nous continuerons à ce que
notre modèle puisse être mis en place et
on pense que c'est aussi un bon modèle
je suis aussi président de l'union
européenne de cyclisme depuis mars et
nous avons un comité directeur de
l'union européenne la semaine prochaine
dans lequel on va essayer aussi de
dupliquer ce système au niveau européen
en espérant que ce soit aussi possible
au niveau mondial alors pour terminer
mon propos introductif moi je voudrais
quand même venir sur quelques mesures
qui me semblent éventuellement essentiel
dans la lutte contre le dopage
il est quand même à ce côté aussi que
tous les sports en fasse autant que le
nôtre ça ça me semble logique moi je
suis là plus pour parler de ce que je
connais bien sûr qu'il cyclisme
reconnaître que certains font quand même
pas grand chose mais il me semble y
avoir plusieurs actions à mettre en
place il y as sans doute à renforcer
l'action collective et les échanges
entre tous les acteurs de la lutte
contre le dopage
l'agencé française de lutte contre le
dopage les autorités de police et de
gendarmerie je pense particulièrement à
l'eau clape ce qu'est le quai vraiment
aujourd'hui compétent en la matière et
qui à mon avis aussi le garant de bonnes
actions qui sont mises en place
les autorités judiciaires bien sûr les
fédérations nationales internationales
l' agence mondiale antidopage
aujourd'hui il ya parfois trop de
cloisonnement et trop d'interdictions de
communiquer de manière officielle entre
nous et ça c'est préjudiciable à la
lutte à la lutte contre le dopage
il ya des informations qu'on peut
échanger les informations qu'on ne peut
pas échanger et c'est dommage qu'on ne
puisse pas échanger certaines
informations qui nous permettrait en
tout cas d'être plus efficace dans la
lutte contre le dopage
donc il faut quelque part coordonner
l'ensemble des actions parce qu'on a les
uns les autres nous connaît le terrain
et on a on a parfois effectivement aussi
des choses des choses à dire qu'ils
peuvent améliorer la situation
je crois qu'il faut aussi que nous
puissions permettre deuxième proposition
à l' agence française de lutte contre le
dopage qui fait du très bon travail de
voir ses moyens sans doute un peu accrue
parce que connaît les restrictions
budgétaires au niveau de haut niveau de
l'état pour autant cette action de lutte
contre le dopage nécessite quand même
des fonds nécessite des besoins et l'
agence française de lutte contre le
dopage on a aussi on a aussi certains
donc moi je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'il
y ait plus de moyens à cette agence de
lutte contre le contre le dopage
je pense aussi je vous livre c'est un
peu pêle mêle que s'agissant par exemple
de notre sport il faut que les
conditions d'exercice des professions
manager ou de directeur sportif
soit
plus réglementée et notamment la au
niveau international sinon ça n'a pas de
sens dans le sens qu'il me paraît
nécessaire que d'obliger pour exercer
ces professions d'obtenir une licence
haddock et pour obtenir cette licence
il faudrait finalement que l'épreuve de
probité de la personne soit acquise et
dès lors que quelqu'un qui était été
condamné pour des affaires de dopage ne
puisse pas exercer cette mission comme
finalement une sorte d'inscription que j
judiciaire comme ça peut exercer
d'examen comme ça peut empêcher
d'exercer certaines missions dans la
fonction publique d'état ou territoriale
au demeurant et ça nous permettrait
d'ailleurs pour certains managers
douteux de les écarter de notre de notre
sport il faut aussi je pense augmenter
certaines sanctions et certaines succès
suspension notamment
je pense que quand il ya une prise de
produits lourds volontaire de le paix ou
quels que soient les produits deux ans
par un peu court et je crois qu'il faut
aller plutôt vers du 4 ans avec une
deuxième inter deuxième sanction qui
serait l'interdiction à vie parce que la
première sanction est somme toute je
trouve relativement faible en la matière
il faut aussi sanctionner financièrement
les contrevenants qui tirent profit tout
ça c'est organiser éventuellement réseau
certains directeurs sportifs
mais quand même aussi l'athlète ne
soyons quand même pas angélique
l'athlète tire profit de tout ça des
sommes colossales parfois sont gagnés et
donc il est nécessaire de frapper au
porte-monnaie celles et ceux qui
trichent mais pas avec des petites
sanctions avec des sanctions à la
hauteur du préjudice subi
dire qu'un athlète y gagnent 6 ou 8
millions d'euros par an doit pouvoir au
moins être sanctionnés à de tels
montants je crois que c'est aussi comme
ça qu'on pourra lutter efficacement et
je souhaite que parfois le deuxième qui
était lésée attaque le premier pour
préjudice parce que ça se fait pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui
mais le jour où ça arrivera je pense que
les choses évolueront également par
rapport aux athlètes faut pas non plus
être angélique
moi je suis pour la pénalisation de l'
usage de produits dopants en vue de
modifier ses performances si on utilise
un produit dopant et qu'on n'avait pas
l'intention de se doper ou parce qu'on
soignait qu'on oublie de déclarer pas le
pénal n'était pas la réponse adaptée
mais si on utilise un produit dopant en
vue
d'améliorer ses performances et donc
d'organiser une tricherie sportive
il m'apparaît logique qui est une
sanction pénale derrière derrière tout
cela il faut aussi je crois décloisonner
l'aspect de lassus médicale
réglementaire et l'aspect de la lutte
contre le dopage le suivi médical
réglementaire c2c de la prévention c'est
la médecine préventive
on est presque si je schématise dans la
médecine du travail alors que dans
l'antidopage en aidant de la sanction
nous pourrions avoir un socle commun qui
sont toutes les analyses du passeport
biologique qui sont les mêmes que ce
soit pour le passeport biologique ou
pour l'antidopage
et ensuite que ça parte dans deux canaux
différents et là qu'ils soient de la
médecine fédéral est l'hôte de
l'antidopage ton mutualiserait ainsi des
coûts et pouvant peut-être permettre
comme j'ai dit au début de favoriser les
relations entre toutes les toutes les
instances moi je suis aussi pour
l'interdiction des corticoïdes et là
c'est plutôt au niveau de l' agence
mondiale antidopage d'ailleurs au
demeurant
sauf bien sûr pour des utilisations
médicales et dans ces cas là et bien là
en arrêt de travail qui est prescrit
comme c'est prescrit nous en tout cas
dans le dans le vélo vous avez bien un
corticoïde pour vous soigner très bien
vous avez le droit de vous faire soigner
mais dans ces cas là vous serez arrêtés
dix ou quinze jours et pas le
corticoïdes et le lendemain on se prend
là on se prend la compétition donc je
crois qu'il ya une vraie différence de
philosophie entre parfois les anglo
saxons et d'autres nationalités sur les
corticoïdes
les corticoïdes ne souvient pas
angélique améliore la performance et il
faut aussi qu'on puisse les bannir et je
crois que la localisation pour tous les
athlètes me semble aussi indispensable
et pas uniquement pour notre pour notre
sport donc voila moi ce que je peux vous
dire de manière assez assez synthétique
en espérant aussi que tous les sports
soient traitées de la même la même
manière ce qui malheureusement n'est pas
encore n'est pas encore le cas des skis
le doigt pour notre sport aucunement
constituer une circonstance atténuante
des agissements qui ont été les siens
même si aujourd'hui je constate comme ça
va ça va mieux voilà ce que je pouvais
vous dire sur le président et rapporteur
de la mission
en quelques instants merci beaucoup pour
ses propos introductifs on va passer si
vous en êtes d'accord maintenant aux
jeux classiques la question réponse mais
je me tourne tout d'abord vers notre
rapporteur jean jacques lozach l'origine
de cette la création de cette commission
denquête sera porteur mais un merci
monsieur le président et merci à vous
monsieur le président également de votre
contribution
cette réflexion collective vise à lutter
plus efficacement contre le dopage dans
notre pays
je reviens très brièvement sur deux
trois points que vous avez exprimé que
vous avez soulevé un moment vous avez
évoqué ce qui peut être présentée comme
une sorte de terreau favorable à la
pratique du dopage
c'est à dire en particulier la présence
dans une équipe du directeur sportif et
du médecin qui effectivement pourraient
être les éléments incitateur pour faire
que telle ou telle cyclistes passent à
une pratique interdite
est ce que vous croyez pas que à
l'intérieur d'une équipe notamment d'une
équipe professionnelle
il est aujourd'hui très difficile de de
sérier les responsabilités à l'intérieur
du groupe
c'est à dire que c'est toute une équipe
qui est gangréné par cette pratique ou
qui ne l'est pas est ce que vous croyez
qu'on peut comme ça opéré distinguo
entre les uns et les autres via
qu'effectivement le degré de
responsabilité peut être variable entre
les acteurs d'une même équipe
c'est vrai que les degrés de
responsabilité peuvent être différents
mais vous avez finalement deux
catégories d'equipe celle où le dopage a
pu être institutionnalisé ou organisé
par l'équipe
celle où aujourd'hui il n'est pas du
tout et où l'équipe plus de contrôles
dopage mais pour autant sur a
généralement entre 25 et 30 coureurs
dans les équipes du world tour du top
niveau
vous n'êtes pas à l'abri d'un
comportement individuel déviant dans une
équipe est donc généralement c'est
sanctionner par par l'équipe moi je
reste quand même persuadé que le manager
c'est lui le patron de l'équipe c'est à
lui de s'organiser pour que son équipe
fonctionne comme elle doit fonctionner
et que de toute manière c'est sa
responsabilité de mettre en oeuvre
toutes les mesures pour que la lutte
contre le dopage soit efficace dans son
équipe et pas d'aller recruter le
médecin le plus performant le médecin
n'est là que pour soigner un certain
nombre de pathologies
et pas pour entraîner ou améliorer les
performances donc ramenons le médecin a
son rôle et le direct et l'entraîneur à
son rôle mais le médecin n'est pas un
entraîneur donc par définition moi
j'aurais tendance à dire le responsable
c'est quand même le patron de l'équipe
et le manager est une équipe c'est comme
un petit monde quand vous vivez toute
l'année ensemble il ya quand même des
choses qui ceux qui se savent et si le
manager n'est pas au courant de ce qui
se passe dans son équipe
pardonnez moi c'est pas un bon manager
oui alors manager au directeur sportif
justement un certain moment vous avez
apporté je dirais une réflexion
concernant le statut notamment au niveau
européen sur votre volonté d'être plus
exigeants en ce qui concerne ce statut
délivré à tel ou tel manager des équipes
d' équipes professionnelles le problème
c'est qu'on a quand même aujourd'hui à
l'intérieur des équipes professionnelles
un certain nombre de directeurs sportifs
qui à un moment ou à un autre
oui à faire au dopage que vous croyez
pas que le moment est venu justement
d'être plus sélectif ce qui concerne ses
responsables des équipes alors très
certainement très certainement prêt il
faut se dire aussi est ce que certains
n'ont pas eu ce qu'un homme peut changer
est ce que parce qu'on a eu un égarement
il ya une vingtaine d'années est ce que
pour autant aujourd'hui on n'a en fait
pas des convaincus de la lutte contre le
dopage
la question mérite d'être d'être posée
mais certains ont continué à mon sens
les agissements qui étaient les leurs en
tant que coureur lorsqu'ils sont devenus
directeurs sportifs et c'est
effectivement cela qu'on ne veut plus
voir dans le dans le vélo et il ya quand
même des manières pouvoir le faire mais
avec le world tour c'est un peu plus
dramatique c'est qu'avant il était
simple directeur sportif mais
aujourd'hui puisqu'ils sont souvent
propriétaires pour certains d'entre eux
de la licence protour
parce que comme par hasard ce sont les
mêmes qui sont souvent propriétaires de
la licence protour
prenez ceux qui sont convaincus de la
lutte contre le dopage parfois ils sont
pas propriétaires de la licence parce
que c'est pas leur philosophie et les
mêmes qui sont parfois ceux qui nous ont
emmenés dans les difficultés dans
lesquelles nous sommes sont aussi
propriétaires de la licence sont aussi
celles et ceux qui souhaitent continuer
continuer d'utiliser les oreillettes et
qui sont aussi celles et ceux qui
souhaitent mettre en place une ligue
fermée donc quelque part laissé nous
organiser notre petite affaire
tranquillement entre nous bah c'est cela
qu'on ne souhaite qu'on soit très
clairement combattre donc il ya vraiment
deux visions du cyclisme qui
s'affrontent aujourd'hui et qui
continueront de s'affronter j'espère que
la vision la plus vertueuse l'emportera
c'est en tout cas le souhait que je
portais c'était aussi le sens de ma
candidature au niveau européen
parce que dans notre suivi médical nous
réglementaire quand on a mis en place en
france
il est indépendant il est indépendant au
niveau international pour l'instant on
demande finalement on a le passeport
biologique c'est de l'antidopage
mais par contre le suivi réglementaire
on demande aux équipes de le faire moi
j'ai pas confiance
alors certes on de l'équipe et je
demanderai pas aux équipes de le faire
vous venez de nous expliquer qu'il y a
deux conceptions qui s'affrontent au
sein des responsables dans le cyclisme
selon vous sont tus ou une obligation de
réponse pour cent moins directement
avez vous le sentiment que dans d'autres
sports il est cette double vision si
j'étais plus qu'au cas je vous dirais
même que j'ai peur que pour dans un
passeport qu'avec la première vision
mais bon faut pas je crois que faut pas
généraliser
là on vous a le droit d'être qu'aucun
deux fois la france et votre opinion
mais moi c'est je pense que comme dans
tout sport il y a des gens vertueux et
des gens qu'ils sont qui sont moins et
faut essayer de faire en sorte que ceux
qui sont moins vertueux deviennent
vertueux et que même si c'est pas par
conviction que ce soit par obligation
parce que le système qu'on a mis en
place font qu'ils peuvent pas faire
autrement oui pour prolonger la question
du président d'alors dans votre propos
liminaire vous avez parlé je vous cite
de sport dans l'état sanitaire est plus
dégradée que cyclisme faisait référence
à quel sport
le dr lannes il ya quelques temps à la
cité je crois un certain nombre de
sports avec des résultats quand vous
lisez le rapport annuel de la fld je
crois que le cyclisme
elle n'est pas du tout en tête du nombre
de sports ans avec le nombre de
contrôles positifs
je me souviens un jour d'un rapport du
présent bordry qui avait fait des
résultats statistiques sur des cheveux
d'athlète mais de manière par sport à
non nominatifs et je crois que le taux
de 2,2 d'athlètes qui présente l usage
de produits dopants ça voulait pas dire
que les avait utilisées en compétition
une manière interdite mais qu'ils
avaient utilisé des produits dopants
même si c'était en dehors des périodes
où de manière festive
il ya des sports où c'était quand même
beaucoup plus important que dans le
nôtre et c'est qu'ils mettaient
contrairement à l'idée reçue loin de
tout ça alors forcément après si on
regarde quand vous voyez le nombre de
contrôles qu'on annonce cyclisme en
proportion bah c'est peut-être nous
qu'avant de plus de cas positifs mais
quand vous ramenez simplement pour
chantage on en est on en est loin d'un
certain nombre d'autres d'autres sports
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de contrôles
quand avant la loi bon but que n'arrive
à l'époque c'était les fédérations
nationales qui organisait les contrôles
antidopage
93% des contrôles antidopage en france
était fait dans le cyclisme
après il ya la loi bon but qui a pas si
ça sous le contrôle du ministère ça
s'est un peu mis dans l'ensemble des
autres sports donc nous on a une
réduction des contrôles à l'époque
puisqu'on en est quand même beaucoup
plus et puis maintenant ça se déroule
aussi dans l'ensemble des sports et moi
je tiens à saluer aussi le travail de de
qualité qui est fait par par la fld une
seule président notamment en matière de
prévention
ce concert notamment la nécessité de
faire passer un certain nombre de
messages notamment direction de la
jeunesse
est ce que vous croyez pas que lorsque
une affaire de dopage éclate on doit
faire très attention à l'expression
publique
quand je dis aux jeunes théo d'ailleurs
les responsables politiques aussi dans
tout ça va pas simple quand les des
acteurs du mouvement sportif national ou
international
mais par exemple quand au moment de l'
affaire festina en 98 on a un président
de l'uci qui dit c'est un cas isolé
vous croyez pas que c'est une erreur de
jugement une erreur d'appréciation qui
justement peut être préjudiciable à une
certaine vision saine de la pratique
sportive
ce qu'on peut dire en tout cas c'est que
les faits ont démontré que ce n'est pas
un cas isolé que sans doute à l'époque
que c'était la différence peut-être
d'autres
c'était une équipe qui avait
institutionnalisé en son sein le dopage
alors que ça ce panel ça se passait
peut-être de manière plus empirique dans
d'autres dans d'autres équipes mais je
crois qu'il faut qu'une autre expression
collective publique soit quand même
teinté de réalisme sur la réalité de ce
qui se passe au sein de notre sport et
on savait quand même si la fédération a
pris ces mesures dans 98 2 1 une semaine
avant la sphère festi date de mettre en
place le suivi médical réglementaire
c'est qu'on ignorait quand même pas les
difficultés dans lesquelles nous nous
trouvions sauf qu'on n'avait pas de
manier afin de moyens efficaces de
pouvoir lutter contre donc effectivement
prudents dans nos agissements et je
pense qu'en matière de dopage faut
jamais jurer du voisin sage
dominique bailly
oui monsieur le président vous vous
évoquer les difficultés relationnelles
avec en particulier le cyclisme
professionnel et gouvernance la place
des fédérations mais très concrètement
là vous êtes en responsabilité de la
fédération
il me semble que le le cyclisme amateur
est aussi touchée par ce phénomène du
dopage et très concrètement depuis que
vous êtes en responsabilité quelles sont
les mesures que vous avez prises pour
contrarier ce phénomène parce que moi
dans les courses amateurs des kermesses
comme il en existe dans ma région ou en
belgique on voit bien que c'est un fléau
donc quels sont les axes forts que vous
avez défendu j'entends bien au niveau
d'une gouvernance européenne et mondiale
mais ici chez nous il ya plusieurs
éléments qui ont été mis en oeuvre
tout d'abord ce suivi médical
réglementaires auxquelles c'est la
plupart de ces de ses coureurs amateurs
en tout cas de première catégorie ne
sont pas soumis de par la loi puisqu'ils
sont pas athlètes de haut niveau ni
athlètes sur les listes espoirs sont
soumis à ce suivi médical réglementaires
dans les mêmes formes que les autres par
décision de la fédération française de
cyclisme doxa c'est une vraie mesure de
notre de notre fédération
deuxièmement on a responsabilisé aussi
un médecin par équipes de division
nationale donc tous ces clubs de
division nationale où un médecin qui
n'est pas un prête-nom mais qui est en
charge de mettre en place aussi de
l'ensemble du suivi de la prévention au
niveau des athlètes
nous avons aussi une autre ligne
budgétaire affectée aux contrôles
sanguins inopinés donc et où là on
mesure finalement des interdictions
notamment de départ comme ça se passait
dans auparavant au niveau de l'ue si on
cumule plusieurs plusieurs critères des
taux d'hématocrite une stimulation
d'hémoglobine et on vient faire des
contrôles
notamment plus sur les courses à étapes
pour les championnats de france parce
qu'il faut quand même que les coureurs
soient regroupés on peut pas les laits
individuellement les chercher chez eux
et là on fait des ont fait des contrôles
est généralement assez couplée avec la
fld ce qui nous permet en fonction des
résultats des anomalies goudé des
résultats tant gens qu'on aurait trouvé
le matin de faire un contrôle urinaire
immédiatement après et comme ça on
arrive à coincer effectivement un
certain nombre de contrevenants dont le
cyclisme amateur va beaucoup mieux qu'il
a été pour autant parce que
statistiquement on a moins de contrôle
dans le cyclisme amateur que dans le
cyclisme professionnel il ya aussi des
questions de moyens
je lui ai dit de partage de entre
l'ensemble des sports d'enveloppés
constante au niveau de la fld le monde
du cyclisme amateur voudrait plus de
contrôles de contrôle antidopage
donc voila nous les mesures que l'on a
prises au niveau de la fédération mais
on a aussi besoin d'être sûrs sur ce
sujet
la globalité ça fait combien sur la
lutte contre le dopage la nulle autre
budget de la globalité de nous ce qu'on
y met sur la lutte antidopage en aux
alentours de 600 mille euros à peu près
sur un budget de 15 millions
jean pierre chauveau bonjour juste deux
petites questions assez concrètes sur
les tours comme la vuelta et le giro est
ce que les contrôles sont quasiment
identiques que sur le tour de france est
autrement en tant que président de la de
l'union européenne de cyclistes est-ce
que vous avez des non pas des pouvoirs
mais est-ce que vous travaillez vous
arrivez à bien travailler avec les
autres fédérations des autres pays alors
deux questions sur la vuelta et le giro
les contrôles sont pas dire ce sont les
mêmes avec quand même des approches
politiques différentes tailles en italie
je crois comprendre qu'au niveau
politique à la même volonté qu'en france
de lutter contre le dopage en espagne
ces notes ont été quand même mais quand
contador a été prix positif et le
premier ministre de l'époque et leaders
de l'opposition avaient tous les deux
immédiatement appelé à soutenir contador
jose magie imaginer qu'en france ça se
produise ainsi on a bien vu l' affaire
puerto
ou alors c'est quand même assez rare on
a là on a là un prévenu qui veut donner
tout le nom de ses clients qui se sont
cons utilisé des produits dopants est
juste qu'il dise surtout ne les donnez
pas donc moi j'ai encore jamais vu ça
d'eau c'est vrai que je pense qu'il ya
pas la même révolution culturelle ni la
même volonté en espagne ce qui se passe
particulièrement au tour de france ces
cas quand même la peur du gendarme
la peur du gendarme non seulement bien
sûr des contrôles antidopage qui sont
très strictes renforcée des contrôles
aussi avec la fld mais on sait que le
club s'est un peu partout on sait qu'à
des gendarmes en civil où des policiers
en civil un peu partout et donc il ya
une peur du gendarme et je crois que
cette peur du gendarme au sens large du
terme
elle est aussi au moins efficace que la
lutte antidopage
elle même et c'est pour ça que mon
premier point visait à renforcer toutes
ces collaborations entre toutes celles
et ceux qui peuvent détenir ou des
moyens d'actions ou des informations
parce que nous pouvons avoir
information mais c'est comme les autos
les autorités policières et judiciaires
qui ont les moyens d'action donc voilà
ce sont les mêmes contrôles mais sans
doute une peur du gendarme renforcer sur
le tour de france compte tenu de la
médiatisation au niveau européen
moi j'ai été élu avec un programme qui
était quand même très strictes sur la
lutte contre le dopage et qui proposait
de généraliser finalement ce qu'on
connaît en france au niveau européen
j'ai obtenu 72 % des voix donc je
t'attends à montrer quand même que les
fédérations européennes se sont
retrouvés aussi dans ce programme là et
là nous discutons la semaine prochaine
de la feuille de route de la commission
médicale présidée d'actes d'ailleurs par
le docteur maigret le médecin fédéral de
la fédération à qui on a aussi chargé de
réfléchir au niveau européen pour mettre
la même chose en place moi je souhaite
vraiment que ça aille plutôt encore au
niveau international même si l'europe
c'est 85% du vélo ce n'est pas 100%
alain dufaut puis stéphane mazars oui
c'est président juste un petit mot sur
la peur du gendarme qui effectivement
existe dans la pays et qui est accentuée
par une loi qu'on a voté à quatre cinq
ans qui permet désormais aux gendarmes
de mettre en garde à vue dès qu'il
trouve dans une chambre d'hôtel du
produit dopant ce qui n'était pas le cas
auparavant
et ça nous avait été demandé par les par
les gendarmes les séries c'est très
efficace
ça permet effectivement de de pouvoir
interroger et de remonter la filière
toujours le couvert qu'il faut c'est
aussi des les pourvoyeurs de produits
dopants qui qui nous intéresse dans la
lutte contre le dopage alors sur la
ferme sont passés quand même les uns des
éléments majeurs
on a bien compris qui l'uci avec un fait
preuve de pas mal de complicité pour
couvrir tous les événements liés au
dopage dans ses rangs de son équipe
est ce que vous pensez pas que en termes
d'efficacité si on veut vraiment tourné
la page il faut changer la direction du
lycée
on va jusqu'au bout alors la limite de
clôture des candidatures c'est le 27
juin prochain
aujourd'hui on a un candidat déclaré
qu'elle président mcquaid pour la
démocratie peut être aussi sain qu'il y
en est qu'il y en ai plusieurs
maintenant il y a des il faut quand même
reconnaître les efforts qui ont été
faits par l'union cycliste
internationale il ya comme des efforts
manifestes qui ont été faits aucune
autre fédération au monde aujourd'hui
n'en fait autant que l'union cycliste
internationale par contre faut aussi
reconnaître que l'image de l'institution
est particulièrement dégradé et après
c'est au au 42 votants qu'il
appartiendra de se prononcer le 20
septembre prochain sur qui sera le mieux
à même de conduire aux destinées de lucé
mais moi ce que je vois c'est que notre
fédération internationale ne pas être
pas être sensé son conflit avec l'agencé
mondiale antidopage avec l'usada avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et c'est
préjudiciable aussi à l'image d'autres
de notre sport donc voilà
il ya trois mois qui vont et sans doute
relativement intense n'a jamais été
tentée d'être vous même candidat mais
c'est des coups est très lu donc donc on
m'a sollicité pour on m'a sollicité pour
être candidat à la présidence de l'ue si
ça peut être une mission une mission une
mission intéressante quand j'ai encore
aussi pas mal de missions à remplir dans
la fédération qui est la mienne est
aussi à la fédération européenne mais
laissons le temps jusqu'aux de regarder
comme on dit dans la course vélo qui
aura pris son dossard le fin à fin juin
prochain j'ai bien compris pas pour
l'instant
voilà stéphane mazars s'il se présente
c'est le président vous avez déclaré
tout à leur être favorable à la
pénalisation de l'usaj les produits
dopants est ce que est ce que c'est une
crainte chez les coureurs que cette
pénalisation existe est ce que vous
sentez que ça peut avoir en réalité réel
impact sur sur leur comportement
un effet notamment dissuasif sa première
question deuxième question vous avez
également déclaré que systématiquement
dans tous les procès la fédération se
constituer partie civile
est-ce que vous contenter de demander
l'euro symbolique ou est ce que vous
arrivez à chiffrer les dommages et
intérêts est ce que est ce que vous avez
des sommes assez conséquente qui vous
sont qui vous sont octroyés par les
juridictions parce que je crois
qu'effectivement à chaque fois c'est
l'image du cyclisme qui est ternie et la
fédération sur la pénalisation du ce la
pénalisation
après reste à savoir quelle est la
sanction pénales encourues par par par
l'athlète mais c'est quand même des
choses qui font qu'ils font réfléchir
mon idée était vraiment de pénaliser de
manière pénale lorsqu'il ya une volonté
de tricher passablement l'utilisation du
produit mais quand le produit est
utilisé à destination d'améliorer donc
ses performances et je pense très
sincèrement c'est une une démesure ya
pas une seule mesure dans la lutte
contre le dopage
c'est une des mesures en tout cas qui
permettrait de dissuader un certain
nombre de
d'athlètes qui souhaitent utiliser des
produits dopants quant aux dommages et
intérêts moi je reste persuadé que le
jour où nous aurons des dommages
intérêts qui ne seront plus l'euro
symbolique
on aura aussi marqué des points parce
que là on aura comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure il faut frapper il faut frapper
au portefeuille
notre constitution de partie civile est
maintenant pratiquement tout elle est
toujours acceptés on a généralement
l'euro symbolique
on a parfois des sommes plus importantes
malheureusement et paix à son âme je
sais qu'il vient de décéder dans la
sphère beaumont nous avions obtenu je
crois que c'est quinze mille euros en
son temps pour le préjudice d'image subi
par notre part notre fédération et nous
réfléchissons sur la sphère amstrong
parce qu'on a clairement un préjudice
d'image
sauf que pour attaquer amstrong là pour
le coup faut avoir les reins un petit
peu solides
on a 49 mille euros de fonds propres à
la fédération vous prenez appelle le
premier rendez-vous est qu un avocat
américain
reste à savoir quel est l'âge et les
législations applicables ou il faut
l'attaquer en france aux états unis mais
nous avons subi un préjudice d'image
dès le 30 août dernier nous avons
demandé à l'époque trois choses qu'on
lui retire ses sept tours de france
je remarque que tout le monde s'est
aligné sur notre position qu'on lui
réclame les deux millions neuf cent
cinquante mille euros perçus de droit
pas de prix de course
et troisièmement qu'ils puissent être
condamnés en terme de préjudice d'image
qui a subi un préjudice d'image nous
c'est évident est ce qu'on peut y aller
tout seul devant les juridictions mais
j'ai bien en tout cas l'attention de
pouvoir continuer sur ce dossier
amstrong sur le préjudice d'image subi
par notre fédération dans la limite
aussi nos moyens et voir si une action
concertée peut être mis aussi en place
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes
dans ce dossier merci à la mairie
oui monsieur le président on vient
d'avoir avec joie constater qu'à eu un
accord grâce à la au mystère de jeunesse
et des sports pour le prochain tour de
france puisque on reçoit des contrôles
antidopage
comment allez vous vous impliquez pour
être sûr que à ce niveau là puisque
c'est aussi la responsabilité de la
fédération
les choses se passent tout à fait tel
que prévu dans l'accord et deuxièmement
en fait j'aurais voulu avoir votre avis
sur la sphère longo où on en est
et quelle sur les suites qui peuvent
encore être prises en a près desquelles
des surprises par rapport à jeannie
longo il ya plusieurs choses donc la
faire sur l'accord qui a été conclu
entre l'uci et la fld j'aurais du mal à
le faire appliquer j'en ai pas de copie
donc voilà mais ça viendra
ça viendra peut-être s'agissant quand
même il ya eu des discussions
fictivement bilatérales nous suivons le
règlement international on est sur une
course internationale
nos compétences de l'union cycliste
internationale qui a effectivement
traités de l' agence française de lutte
contre le dopage est accepté d'échanger
un certain nombre de données sur la
localisation notamment
suivant le règlement international nous
sommes nous charger fédération nationale
de la mise en oeuvre technique en fait
des contrôles sauf que la partie du
moment effectivement il y avait un
accord direct de pouls de deux traités
il ya toujours des dispositifs spéciaux
au tour de france toujours le tour de
france est un événement complètement à
part du sport français du sport du sport
mondial
donc on est naturellement moins impliqué
dans les contrôles qu'on peut l'être
dans les autres dans les autres
contrôles qui sont qui sont menées donc
là l'agencé française de lutte contre le
dopage aura effectivement pour charge de
mettre en oeuvre la partie technique de
l'ensemble des contrôles et c'est plutôt
une bonne chose qu'un accord a été a été
conclu entre le cio et la fnb quant à la
sphère longo il yal'affaire longo et la
faire aussi prelic et son mari c'est
deux choses différentes en droit
aujourd'hui
jeannie longo
n'est pas mise en examen n'a pas de deux
sont deux risques encourus elle a été
renvoyée devant une commission
disciplinaire de la fédération pour à
l'époque des vices de forme non pas de
notre part mais de la fld sur sa
notification de l'appartenance au groupe
cible là notre fédération donc a été
obligé de constater qu'il y avait un
vice de forme et donc la relaxe est ce
qu a ensuite confirmé d'ailleurs et
l'agencé française de lutte contre le
dopage et donc il y avait eu
effectivement vice de forme de la part
de la fld doc jeannie longo n'encourt
pas de sanction en tant que tel pour
autant son mari l'an née de complètement
différent de deux manières différentes
il y à une procédure judiciaire qui a
été ouverte nous sommes parties civiles
dans cette affaire comme dans tous les
dossiers
c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est pas parce
qu'il s'agit de même langue que nous ne
saurait faute son mari du moins que nous
ne saurions pas partie civile
nous sommes parties civiles va bien sûr
accès à l'ensemble des éléments des
éléments du dossier et je crois savoir
que aujourd'hui le juge d'instruction
n'a pas souhaité lever le contrôle
judiciaire qui pèse sur monsieur
ciprelli donc c'est qu'il a sans doute
des interrogations fortes sur son
implication dans un certain nombre
d'affaires de dopage
les produits servait-il à sa femme bah
il conviendra au juge de le de le dire
marie thérèse bruguière pour une une
question et ensuite deux ou trois
questions pour terminer de l'apport de
l'autre rapporteur question monsieur le
président comme il ya deux factions de
sanctions sont prises à peu près par an
car j'ai plus le j'ai pu si je crois
qu'on l'a transmis par ce qu'on a on a
dû transmettre un tableau avec à votre
la commission denquête avec le les
statistiques disciplinaire alors entre
2006 et 2012 voyez on a 17 ans quand on
est encore sanctionné un nombre de
dossiers disciplinaires 17 en 2006 23 en
2007 13 en 2008
16 14 10 13 3 dire que c'est une
quinzaine après par an globalement en
disciplinaire
alors programmateur et professionnelle
voilà en disciplinaire antidopage
voilà en disciplinaire antidopage et
vous voyez donc à chaque fois on a
rarement dépassé un professionnel par an
1 01 et on va dire que 90% se rend
auprès des amateurs sera porter leur
avance je me permets de le signaler
oui monsieur le président vous venez
donc maintenant je dirais un combat au
niveau européen comme président de
l'union européenne de cyclisme
j'ai noté en particulier que votre
adversaire avait été andreï tchmil qui
moldave et vous savez que la moldavie
est un pays un peu particulier en ce qui
concerne le dopage puisque voilà un pays
qui est au plein coeur de l'europe et
qui fabriqué produits en toute légalité
en toute liberté des stéroïdes
anabolisants
est ce que vous allez faire de votre de
votre mandat à la tête de l'union
européenne de cyclisme un combat contre
ce type de pratiques
alors effectivement normalement sont des
produits interdits à l'exportation mais
on sait très bien qu'à partir du moment
où la circulation est libre ce
territoire national il est toujours
facile ensuite de de l'importer ou de
l'exporter
je crois même savoir que mon concurrent
et ministre des sports de ladite
moldavie donc je vous dirais qu'il y
avait effectivement on pouvait y avoir
deux versions du sport qui qui qui
s'affrontaient après faut pas non plus
exagérer les pouvoirs qu'on en tant que
président d'une union européenne de
cyclisme avec un seul salarié
face à des organisations d'état qui peut
y avoir face aux et dauphin et je crois
que c'est pour ça qu'on doit renforcer
toute la coopération
judiciaires policières mail à l'échelle
européenne même en au delà de l'échelle
de l'union européenne parce qu'on voit
bien que là on a des pays qui
n'appartiennent pas à l'union européenne
mais au delà même de la de la moldavie
il ya aussi tout un tas d'autres pays
dans le monde où c'est tous les produits
donc et on peut acheter tout cela par
par internet donc il faut effectivement
s'attaquer aux lieux de production mais
bien sûr aussi à l'ensemble des trafics
et puis à celles et ceux moi je souhaite
que celles et ceux qu'ils utilisent et
la certitude d'être à un moment des
masques et condamnés je reviens sous la
président de l'uci que vous soyez
candidat ou pas avant une élection il ya
une campagne électorale pour y résident
d'une fédération qui représente une
nation importante dans le cyclisme
international
est-ce que vous souhaitez mettre au
coeur de la campagne électorale la
question du dopage
il me semble essentiel que le sujet de
la lutte contre le dopage soit au coeur
de la prochaine campagne au niveau de
l'ue c'est simplement les campagnes
internationales
je suis moi même et le local je suis
maire conseiller général on les mène pas
de la même manière c'est plus feutrée il
n'y a pas beaucoup de votants avec 42
donc c'est du corps à corps avec les
lecteurs donc c'est qu'on va dire c'est
presque une élection sénatoriale mais
raccourcie encore avec un corps
électoral beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
faible j'ai moi même voter pour les
élections sénatoriales donc mais on a
peu d un peu d'électeurs donc c'est un
sujet majeur
mais les sujets grand public sont
peut-être pas les sujets qui pour un
certain nombre de votants sont les
sujets principaux
donc voilà le la gouvernance du sport
mondial pourrait mériter aussi une après
midi de débats
le votre médecin fédéral mais ce maigre
et parle assez régulièrement d'un retour
des corticoïdes en peloton alors fi du
mans il ya eu différentes différentes
époques dans l'histoire du dopage en
cyclisme rfec admin le p o et c est ce
qu on assiste à un retour des
corticoïdes
d'après vous on a effectivement dû usage
de corticoïdes qui est qui revenue dans
le dans le peloton
pourquoi parce qu'il a été plus ou moins
légalisé par l' agence mondiale de lutte
de fall agence mondiale antidopage
à l'époque donc moi je le regrette je le
regrette profondément
en considérant que c'était pas forcément
un produit dopant
or des études scientifiques publiées
aujourd'hui ont montré que il avait un
effet de produits dopants donc pour moi
les corticoïdes doivent être sur la
liste des produits interdits
si on en a besoin lorsqu'on se soigne et
bien on arrête le vélo pendant la durée
pendant laquelle on soigne c'est aussi
simple que ça et enfin le président est
ce que vous êtes
est ce que la fédération française est
destinataire des résultats des contrôles
réalisés sur le tour pardus et y a sur
le tour pendant du sehy non non et on
l'a d'ailleurs on l'a jamais il me
semble pas qu'on les cons l'été parce
qu'il ya toujours je veux pas dire une
loi d'exception mais une on est chez
nous on est destinataire que des
contrôles positifs lorsqu'ils concernent
des coureurs français
j'ai reçu aujourd'hui ont recommandé
d'ailleurs puisque c'était dans le
journal on l'a vu le cas d'un coureur
français sanctionnés pour vaquer qui a
utilisé des produits dopants élus cm
notifie lorsque c'est un coureur qui est
du ressort de notre fédération donc avec
une licence française mais nous n'avons
pas les résultats de du tour de france
ni tout à fait merci le seul président à
la mairie pour 2011 réserver votre
conclusion vous étiez vous étiez contre
les en dessous quelque chose la
dépénalisation des corticoïdes et et
vous dites si on est malade en s'arrête
donc j'en conclus que vous êtes contre
les invités
quelle est votre position par rapport je
suis contre les invités de circonstances
mais il peut quand même y avoir
aujourd'hui des personnes qui présentent
une vraie pathologie une vraie
pathologie qui ont le droit de faire du
sport et c'est aux médecins de dire si
la battle fall usage de tels produits
est de nature à améliorer ou pas la
performance
et si elle peut être autorisée au pas on
a des personnes qui ont un vrai problème
médical et qu'il faut aussi pouvoir
traiter sans pouvoir forcément leur
interdire le sport donc moi je suis
contre tout ca du t2 de circonstance
si vous en êtes d'accord monsieur le
président je suis désolé d'être directif
quelques mois pour conclure parce que le
temps passe vite avec vous et on aurait
bien voulu poursuivre mais on va être
obligé d'arrêter dans cinq minutes
moi je forme le voeu qu'on puisse avoir
une vision prospective de la lutte
contre contre le dopage
il ya des faits qui se sont passés il ya
un certain temps dans notre sport
je suis pas sûr qu'il faille sans arrêt
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé il ya
quinze ans parce que c'est pas forcément
comme cela qu'on va avancer et regarder
l'avenir avec avec sérénité
par contre au contraire il faut
développer l'ensemble des coopérations
qui permettront efficacement de lutter
contre le dopage
que ce soit un objectif partagé des
états des acteurs du monde sportif
international du cio des acteurs des
fédérations internationales et que nous
renforcions et le code mondial
antidopage éventuellement mais où toute
la collaboration policière en la matière
est d'ailleurs sans doute qu'on les
tentes sur un autre domaine sur lesquels
je suis convaincu que rossi
prochainement des ravages aussi
important c'est tout le sujet des paris
en ligne
et où notre sport n'est pas à l'abri de
ce qui peut arriver même si pour
l'instant nous avons été épargnés
merci
monsieur le président pour ma part je
retiens ce que vous avez dit concernant
la pénalisation de l'usaj vous êtes l'un
des premiers nous parlait pénalisation
de l'usaj merci pour l'ensemble de vos
propos c'était une un message important
que nous avons bien enregistré je le dis
à chacun de nos interlocuteurs
dans l'hypothèse où nous aurions besoin
avant la mi-juillet de précisions
complémentaires
on se permettra si vous en êtes d'accord
de faire à nouveau appel à vous vous
inquiétez pas vous préviendra
suffisamment tôt et ce sera beaucoup
plus court mais merci d'être venu devant
nous et merci d'avoir tenu les propos
que vous avez tenus
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sénatoriale consacré à
l'efficacité de la lutte contre le
dopage
si vous souhaitez revoir ses auditions
ou en savoir plus sur les travaux de la
commission notre site internet
publicsenat.fr bonne fin de journée à
tous